thanks everybody for for joining the
session uh it's about the data flow and
test for machine learning pipelines
we've developed Ino guide uh I I'm doing
this talk together with steo uh my
colleague he having some tech technical
difficulties uh but uh he uh will join
uh the session as we
proceed but for the sake of time I'll
will get started so um yeah first point
is a little bit about who we are
so uh so my name is Jan I'm a data
science manager in Geto guide uh and
Geto guide for those who don't know is a
Online Marketplace for travel
experiences I work there together with
Ste which is a my French coworker he's
also a data science manager in getro
guide we um have a lot of data in Geto
guide and tons of machine learning
running in production uh and that means
also that there is a lot of ml pipelines
to be optimized that we are working on
daily so uh for and that was the origin
basically of this project of the data
flow with that said um I will introduce
the agenda for today so let's start with
like understanding the challenges around
testing machine learning
pipelines uh then uh what we
discover to be like a need for a tool
that kind of help us to do better and to
test of machine learning pipelines how
we implemented this to and then we want
to conclude with some learnings uh from
from this
process let's get started so what are
challenges around testing ml
pipelines so um first of all let's let's
go back to principles and think what
what it's testing about right so uh
testing is about
changing um changing our systems uh in a
way that uh we with confidence like we
getting feedback for the changes we are
making in the systems so like uh there
is one aspect of it is the feedback loop
so I make a change in my system how fast
can I see that this change is actually
doing what I wanted or there is a
problem with it this is one kind of very
Central Point in software productivity
so if you have a fast feedback loop you
can um yeah iterate very quickly try out
different things and move on Fast uh but
M pipelines bring unique challenges to
this kind of testing um the first let's
take a look on what those challenges
are so first of all there is a lot of
complexity uh ml pipelines have a lot of
data sources to be joined errors don't
need necessarily to be about schema
problems uh they can be also just
distribution problems data distributions
and those are very hard to detect in the
code um also the scale right uh there is
tons of data uh sometimes terabytes of
data to be processed and uh um yeah so
to run that fast and get a fast feedb
loop is rather a challenge finally and
uh it's these systems are operated not
only about within engineers it's a
diverse team that's operating ml
pipelines data scientists people with
academic background and uh they have
very different skill sets from kind of a
um so we have to accommodate for all the
skill sets and that's something we want
to to keep and preserve so um now that
we understand a little bit more what are
the unique challenges of meles uh let's
look into unit test uh for ML unit tests
for ML pipelines is that a viable option
or
not okay can you hear me
yes so can you go to the next slide
please sure uh
sorry yes okay sorry for the start uh I
had some of course Chrome wanted to
restart itself uh I apologize so can we
test uh can we can we unit tml pipeline
we try need to replicate this mindset of
the classical software by adding test
tol pipeline uh in particular uh we try
to have to push to have un cor coverage
on the critical Parts uh but building
and maintaining this uh drag us the
velocity of the team for three specific
reason first one we learned that a lot
of dsod is actually not really unit
testable how do you want to unit test
that the model was train or how do you
want to unit test that the uh that the
code to create the training data has the
right joint condition to make it clear
there are some some specific code or
function that can be easily tested but
lots a big chunk of the D code data
science code was not easily testable
unit testable second one we saw that uh
ml machine learning uh is in constant
res is really research oriented which
means a lot of experimentation and a lot
of the experimentation needs add to uh
some major reflector of the code in very
different and unpredictable way so every
time we had to refactor the code and
also refactor a lot of the unit test
that go
with finally we also saw that even if we
had a good unit test coverage we still
saw error popping out more on the
integration level to to explain a bit
more ml pipeline we usually break down
in multiple steps and we end up changing
one step and everything works on the
unit test level however it end up
breaking another step down the line that
we did not uh
fore so for this reason we uh struggle
uh to uh to unitize the pipeline can you
go to the next slide
please and now the we also um we also
struggle a bit with the the the test and
the production data indeed pipeline
combined code with data and in order to
fully test the
pipeline you also need to create
realistic D data which end up being very
time consuming code copilot now can help
a lot with that but it still come out
some in practice what we saw is that
most of the line of code end up being
hardcoded fake data or code to generate
realistic fake data this creating and
maintaining this is uh is C
and what we still see is that there is
no leak between this fake data and the
production
data and this come as a cost sometime or
having uh a bugs that only appeared in
production so we struggle for some time
to implement these tests and making them
lightweight to maintain and get an
effective coverage while getting limited
benefits from this uh testing strategy
however we saw that in the company level
uh
their endtoend test when done right can
be a great success and so we wonder if
we could improve on
this cool and um yeah let's now zoom
into our process of uh looking to end to
tests and the the end up that ended up
leading us to create the data flow uh so
we started basically with uh trying this
idea let's have a end to end and
pipeline in a project and uh we
basically get all the steps put in a
single script TI that to the C and we
saw very fast that that was great for
validation like uh um there was we get
like feedback back from our system in a
much more kind of reliable way but there
was still a long road ahead of us the
those pipelines was were running though
very slowly there was they were
sequential and there's a lot of kind of
uh um time that one needs to run one
entire pipeline like that so after a
little bit of analysis was clear the
problem was the data there was too many
data into this production pipelines so
the approach we decided for as a
solution for this problem is to sample
the data down um so we reduce the data
for the CI and uh so we can have the
entire pipeline running much
faster um yeah we we also saw this is a
need of any
project and there's probably a space
here for a tool we look also into the uh
ecosystem our stack is python PL spark
and we couldn't find any tool that would
solve this problem uh for this
particular ecosystem so we decided to
build one
ourselves
um and now one of the key design
decisions I want to explore a little bit
is like if you sample in a centralized
fashion or a decentralized Prof
centralized means you create a parallel
data warehouse with like all the data
items but much smaller just a sample of
them and then when in your pipeline you
just change your database source to be
this kind of to point to this uh sample
data warehouse that's one approach the
other approach is decentralization which
means move the sampling to each ml
pipeline so they own the sampling there
um with with the centralized approach
it's very easy to get started that's a
big plus um so you just need to change a
single parameter the date Warehouse
name on the other hand there is a lot of
more kind of lower end of the funnel
costs you create a centralized
infrastructure maintaining it becomes
expensive um and over time definitively
will happen that this data will drift
away from from its original production
data so how to maintain these things can
be come very
tricky on the decentralized end you have
a lot complete control over the sampling
uh strategy you always have access to
real data the downside is that you need
to much more effort to in the initial
setup right you need to set up sampling
for each project in the end we landed
with the decentralized option as uh it's
basically is scos better it's more
self-service and that's a good
attributes for platform work like this
uh that we believe on in getra guide so
with that in mind now is overview of how
the data flow looks like it has
basically sampling functions that are
applied conditionally into the pipeline
if you are in production or in
theci uh that's a very high level view
too will basically go deeper and show
how this looks in
practice should I yes in yes sh um what
I propose is that I will adjust to the
slides we go until the conclusion and I
will do the demo
afterwards okay so so then we okay
continue okay sounds
good
so yeah so here I will show you a bit
more how how we do the how we declare
the data sources so that we'll be able
so we have the data flow and then you
will need to have a config where you
declare the sources uh your data sources
where you say how you will need to write
to read the data that you you you need
and afterwards how you can filter which
is only used when you want to sample the
data and so for each of your data
sources you can define a different
filter because not all of them have the
same uh my need the same logic for
filtering and once your config is there
then you can uh in say initialize the
data flow uh object okay now let's see
the different modes the first one is
when we have D data flow enabled which
mean that uh we have the data sources
but we want to sample them so first I
will go through the filter then where
they will be sampled and finally then
can be piped through to your ml pipeline
but then you just have the sample data
which will run faster and then you can
run it on your
CI the second mode um
is when you have the data flow disabled
here at this point we want to run in
production so we want to get the data
the data sources and directly have the
full data set pushed to the to the to
the ml pipeline to have the model that
you want to use in
production and finally the last
one uh is uh when we want to use uh
local development here we also want to
uh develop to to get the data sources
sample but then what we want is to be
able to download this uh small uh sample
data on your local machine to be able to
uh iterate faster with this uh re with
this sample but uh uh realistic
data okay we also have a demo we'll try
to do at the end uh but first let's go
through the conclusion and uh then I
will do the demo all right so as
now we having this two in place we uh we
really enabled our teams to have like
end to end tests uh with real data in
the CI uh this uh to give some data
points there is like uh how
much uh a pipeline would take in the CI
before and after the data flow so it can
really speed up a lot and uh it makes
the feedback loop much faster than
before to understand if your code is
working detects earlier much much
earlier problems uh and allow new use
cases actually to enter the CI that
before would even be considered uh as
possible um and in conclusion uh like d
data flow now is integral part of
majority of our ml pipelines in
production uh it had a transformative
impact into uh our pipeline
efficiency uh it also had delivered
value at scale with small tools is a
very good practice within our
organization that we believe in small
tools building adding value uh and being
self-service um rather than trying to
build like ends to an ml
platform we find we find that uh ml
productivity is much better served with
small very targeted tools that are
self-service as well uh yeah and we are
looking for the feedback from the
community the two is open so you can try
it out and uh now let's go to the
demo okay so can you stop sharing I will
uh start sharing again and
okay one second sh screen and I want to
share this screen
three no still not I
can uh just a second let me try
something else
window I will share
my I still have some problem I I don't
know why the
demo punishing
us okay let me try let me try to share
this okay great I cannot share my the
full screen but I can share that so I so
first I need I can install the data flow
I can share this you all see it it's
first so and then we can Define the data
sources and here in the data sources
what I'm doing is um taking the
departure those the flight delay uh
which is a kind of Open Source uh data
set around flight flight delays in the
in the word and it compos on two thing
one about the delays itself and another
one about the code airort and for each
of them you can Define the sources how
you want to uh how you can read it and
also the filter afterwards and finally I
can then uh enable uh create the the
data flow object and first as we said as
said before we can have did it for
enabled which means that we will be uh
sampling it and then you can call the
sources by calling through the name that
you defined earlier
here
and here we can display and we see we
have the sources that is uh that have
been sampled the first one just start
with the letter B that's our sample
saturation that we have and the second
one we just say that we want the top 100
rowes then if we want to disable now we
we the CI works so let's imagine we want
to go to production we can then disable
the data flow and what we see
here is that we have then all the letter
in the origin here and the second table
have uh more than 500
rows
okay and finally uh when we want to uh
the data flow the sample the data
basically what we have to do is first to
save the sample data into a folder in
dbfs
and once this is done we see we have
it enabled here and what's uh I will
need to then show how I can run it
locally and for that I will need to stop
sharing and try to share another one
that's what I wanted to avoid so I want
to share
my why is it
not Visual
Studio sh great
H okay I cannot share my my pie charm I
my try second time but
otherwise I think we nevertheless got to
the book of the message with the
notebook
experience yeah and then you can
basically run your the same code that
you have and have also the thing
downloaded on your machine that's will
be able to get the data by itself okay
sorry for the this last technical thing
uh we didn't expect this problem great
that's
it yes I will leave open here just a
link with the data flow it's on GitHub
so uh and we are back we are open to
questions looks like we have one
currently in the Q&A section so if we
navigate there um again anyone who is
listening or anyone who is looking any
get any answers to your questions uh
please drop those in the Q&A we kind of
go through those right
now should I read it out loud does the
data flow only work with spark can you
elaborate more what integration data the
data flow has yeah I think at this one
it only works for spark at the moment uh
I mean it's nothing prevents to have
other kind of distributed data
processing pipelines in place would
require a project to make that work out
but yeah I guess the would be possible
as a open source project to add such
[Music]
support how does the data flow generate
test data is it synthetic or filtered
subset of production data you want to
get that to yeah uh no it's a f filtered
subset of production data so that's
that's was the the main problem that we
have creating synthetic
data uh was very csome and what we saw
is by by using a filtered subset of
production data we could test a lot of
things um and that's why we created this
tool to be able to wrap this logic of
how if you want to filter it uh if you
want to get this how you want to sample
it ET
sure how find gr are futters for sample
Sante dependency in the
data I think I got the gist of it is I
mean
the can we trust the futters in our
pipeline right I guess it's an excellent
question and uh the I think that's the
best we can do right you get the expert
to write the filter itself rather than
trying any other way to kind of filter
the the data so this brings the
filtering problem to the data scientist
who owns the pipeline and then we can
basically figure out the best method for
each specific situation there are some
sort of generic recommendations that we
can give but in the end uh there's a lot
that goes to use case specific uh
[Music]
needs okay could you share the D data
flow repo on the slides so we'll share
the slides uh not sure exactly but how
uh but I'm pretty sure who will be asked
to to share the slide and the URL uh of
the repo you can already get there uh by
the the small QR code or you can also
look for D data flow on PPI up perfect
even
better